hey come on get your stuff let's
[Music]
go let's try that
a you're showing off maybe a little I I
have always really loved Marvel movies
Madame web was very enticing to me hi
Cassie web this movie is before she ends
up in a wheelchair she's hyper
intelligent and her greatest superpower
is her mind I knew he was going to
die I saw
[Applause]
it when Cassie begins to experience her
Clairvoyance she thinks she's losing her
mind you are the only one who can change
the future Madam Webb is unlike any
other superhero when you're thinking
about how Spider-Man flies through the
air or Venom when he changes it's so
mythical to us but with her it's all
psychological I can see the future and I
found that incredibly exciting to
explore let's try that again these
Visions are quite fragmented because she
doesn't see anything clearly I've seen
that man before so who is he Ezekiel
Sims he was in the Amazon with my mom um
right before she died Madame web brings
these four superheroes words together
you don't think this is weird how we're
all
connected it's honestly like the least
weird thing that's happened all day the
Genesis and the Inception of what will
become you're showing off maybe a
little welcome back everyone it's
Charlie Marvel and Sony dropped the new
Madam web trailer so we finally got a
look at what's actually going on so a
bunch of Easter eggs here A bunch of
Spider-Man stuff too so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos but the whole idea is that
you see Dakota Johnson's Cassandra Webb
sort of in the process of getting her
powers like you see her in the future
when she already has her powers of prean
but she hasn't been able to completely
control space and time yet like in the
featurette she says it it's before she
winds up in the wheelchair most people
remember that version of Madam web if
you don't remember Spider-Man the
Animated Series I would definitely
recommend checking it out it is one of
the the best Spider-Man series of all
time but Madam Webb was huge during that
series like the full version of Madam
web in the chair that version was
actually played by Stanley's wife Joan
in real life there was even a joke about
it in one of the final episodes where
Spider-Man Actually travels to a
universe where he meets Stan Lee at the
Marvel offices it was a super meta
episode not the same guy I've been
writing about all these years well Stan
we all have to grow up sometime I
suppose even us characters of fiction
Spiderman it's time to go who is that
exotic lady that's basically Stan Lee
saying that his wife sounds really nice
but the way they start the trailer off
she's actually at the fourstar diner
which is a location from the Spider-Man
comics they're facing off a version of
Ezekiel Sims who has his own Spider-Man
Powers who's coming to kill all these
different versions of characters who
become Spiderwoman because of who they
become but when he's attacking them here
in this Diner they haven't become
Spiderwoman yet Sydney Sweeney is
playing Julia Carpenter you see her in
her costume later in the trailer it
looks like her costume in the comics
this is Ana Corone this is her in her
costume later in the trailer and this is
Maddie Franklin and this is her in her
costume later in the trailer but later
in the timeline obviously so the whole
idea is they have this sort of
Terminator like time travel plot where
you have Dakota Johnson's Madam web
character trying to save them from being
killed in the past by Ezekiel Sims and
even though you only briefly see like
the back of her head like she's not a
big character in these trailers so
probably not till like the next trailer
Emma Roberts is supposed to be playing
Mary Parker Peter Parker's biological
mother and Adam Scott is supposed to be
playing a young version of Uncle Ben
they're supposed to be big parts of the
story so I think part of the idea is
that Ezekiel Sims is going around into
the past Terminator style trying to kill
all these versions of both Spiderman and
Spider Woman I'm really nervous
but for the most part this trailer just
wants to focus on Adam web slowly
getting her powers then throughout the
trailer you see her slowly gaining the
ability to actually control those powers
like control space and time for those of
you wondering this is taking place in
the Venom Universe primarily obviously
connected to Spider-Man Marvel Universe
to tangentially because they already
connected those during Spider-Man no way
home just starting at the beginning of
the trailer though she sees the fourstar
diner like I said location from the
Spider-Man comics this seems like after
she's already learned to control her
powers a little bit but before the other
versions of Spiderwoman have gotten
close to becoming versions of
Spiderwoman like they barely have any
idea of what's going on like there are
versions of Sarah Connor who have no
idea what's going on until you get to
the events of Terminator 2 which seemed
like it happened at some point later in
the movie like they're not waiting to
the sequel before Sarah Connor so to
speak like these versions of Sarah
Connor become badasses this is mattye
Franklin this is Ana Corone this is
Julia Carpenter and I think Mary Parker
might actually be working at this Diner
then we see Ezekiel Sims walking in in
his full Spider-Man suit relatively
speaking he's actually a bit of a newer
Spider-Man villain he debuted in 2001 in
Amazing Spider-Man Volume 2 number 30 he
got his powers from the spider totem
he's connected to Mor Lun a lot of
people wondered if that character would
actually be involved in the spiderverse
movies too just because they're all
connected to the spider Society so to
speak they already connected Spider-Man
across the spiderverse to like the live
action spider movies like Donald
Glover's Prowler is the liveaction one
from Spider-Man homecoming and it
basically sounds like like the idea is
that all these versions of Spiderwoman
Spiderman eventually team up to stop him
in the future and he's trying to come
back into the past to stop them before
that happens basically all of his powers
are like Spider-Man's basic powers like
I said but he got them from the spider
totems he wasn't bitten by a radioactive
spider or anything like that then
basically you see her lose and she
controlling time says let's try this
again and literally tries It Again by
going back in time so it is interesting
to see how they're pulling off her time
traveling ability we see the New York
City landscape she's working as an EMT
because she's trying to save people
using her abilities basically they show
her Venom verse version of her origin
story it's basically like a near-death
experience that starts to unlock her
abilities we see Adam Scott who's
working as an EMT with her who is
supposed to be the younger version of
Uncle Ben during the movie part of the
idea I think is they're also going to
tease the birth of Peter Parker
Spider-Man and maybe at some point
Ezekiel Sims will also try to kill Mary
Parker so that doesn't wind up happening
she starts to see the future she sees a
version of Ezekiel Sims coming to the
subway car walking around on a New York
City train should just be sus enough
like wait a minute you're not wearing
shoes that's the dirtiest thing I've
ever seen something is weird about you
she starts having visions of him killing
all these different versions of
Spiderwoman across the train they
haven't fully explained why all the
different women wind up on the same
train because they didn't get their
powers in the exact same incident like
it all didn't happen at the same time
they don't really give a release date in
the trailer they just say that it's
being released at some point next year
sounds like it's going to be relatively
early next year part of the idea though
I think some of the movie is supposed to
take place about 20 years ago inside New
York City like the technology just makes
it seem like it's 20 years ago just so
the timeline works out with Peter Parker
being an adult in present day there
might be a version of J Jonah Jamon in
the movie because Maddie Franklin is
related to him biologically and he was
obviously operating at this point 20
years before Peter Parker was born if
we're talking about Ezekiel Sims getting
his powers from the spider totem unless
they've changed that for the movie Ana
coron is is one of the other characters
who gets her powers from the spider
Society who granted her abilities using
a ritual but they might just simplify
that for the purposes of the movie and
it looks like they're saying that
Cassandra Web like Madame Webb got her
powers biologically like she says her
mother was researching spiders before
she was born notice he's got the Red
Umbrella that's just meant to be a
Spider-Man e like red for Spider-Man's
costume they kind of did something
similar in the Craven trailer where like
you see him in the woods with spiders
all around him the only difference in
this trailer is that you see a bunch of
people in Spider-Man related costumes
for the most part the women's costumes
are accurate to their comic book
costumes though you see Sydney Sweeney
using a version of her Sonic webbing
from the comic so this is comic book
accurate to her abilities what I'm
guessing though just the way they're
building the hype in the trailer here is
that by the end of the movie you'll see
versions of them using their powers in a
big final battle against him then
there's the obvious time travel Trope
then in her having to save them their
Futures have already been changed a a
little bit like in the original versions
of their timelines where they all became
Spiderwoman she didn't interact with
them in this way so the fact they're
having this version of the first
Terminator movie where she has to say
them Kyle ree style she's already
changing their origin stories so in this
new timeline that they create they'll
have to explain how they get their
powers in a slightly different way
notice the giant red glowing P very
obvious metaphor for Peter Parker notice
in the logo too it's red for Spiderman
also has the webbing all over it and the
outline of the Statue of Liberty and New
York City basically one of the other big
questions when they announced the movie
too is she's going to be part of the
reason why all these different versions
of characters from like say like the
Spider-Man universe connect with the
Venom verse pulling everyone together by
the events of Secret Wars because they
actually kind of did a version of this
during Spider-Man the Animated Series
where she brought Spider-Man to battle
World part of the idea I think that Sony
is trying to build up to like their own
version of Avengers Infinity war and
Avengers end game separately from Secret
Wars and like all the other big
Multiverse crossover stuff with MCU
Spider-Man so I do think in success like
if everything goes well with this movie
and you know who knows big question mark
there they'll use her abilities as a way
to explain how everybody starts coming
together like she'll be the version of
doctor strange that sort of goes around
the Multiverse collecting everyone
putting this Multiverse team of
Spider-Man together there are a bunch of
announcements too in the MCU side of
things about Marvel changing Avengers
King Dynasty Avengers 6 Secret Wars
because they're moving away from the
Kang plot I'll try to do a video about
that at some point in the next couple of
days because that would actually be a
pretty big deal like them pivoting away
from Kang towards Dr Doom if there's any
big Easter eggs or references that you
spotted in the trailers that I didn't
talk about in this video just write them
Below in the comments and I'll do more
videos about Madame Webb as soon as we
get more footage with more of the
characters like more Mary Parker more
Peter Parker Spider-Man easter eggs
hopefully because this movie is set like
20 years ago we won't see Uncle Ben
having to die again but because it is a
Terminator style plot and she gets to
replay events over and over we'll
probably see the characters die a couple
different ways speaking of Sony
liveaction crossover I do think that
we'll see more of that during Spider-Man
beyond the spiderverse I think the idea
is they were sort of Dipping their toe
in that water like liveaction animation
crossover during Spider-Man across the
spiderverse so beyond the spiderverse
will end with like a much bigger version
of that hopefully to prepare some of the
characters like Miles Morales for
liveaction crossover in secret Wars my
early theory is that the post credit
scene will involve some sort of
liveaction Venom crossover kind of like
we saw in the morbius movie with the big
sinister teaser at their post credit
scene probably a couple big Spider-Man
references too in that post credit scene
but everyone click here for my full Loki
season 2 episode 6 finale video and
click here for my Spider-Man beyond the
spiderverse teaser trailer video thank
you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next
[Music]
one